The Narrative went from this was a
incident that is unfortunate and maybe
we need to look at police reform to The
Narrative of black men are constantly in
fear we're always in danger and that
racism is the number one issue affecting
us how did we get to this point in just
a matter of days it to me it felt like a
panic attack to me it just removed our
individuality and we just became this
Collective that was just weak and feeble
for men we are stronger we are deadlier
I mean it's it's the truth to say that
we can inflict pain much easier and we
are dangerous to uh to society if we're
not under control and the job of the
father is to control the energy of the
boy
I I think gangs are a result of Lost
Boys
and then they grow up to become lost men
and I think one of the things that a lot
of people don't understand is especially
women don't understand about men is that
we're Purpose Driven so I think purpose
is extremely important for kids and I
think if you're talking about like gang
violence in particular that's that's one
of those areas that you see what happens
when you don't give young men purpose if
if I label someone as a white
supremacist then what
then what you know they they did it to
themselves they cried wolf too many
times so I'm I'm one of those people who
actually doesn't want to fight the
language I'm going to use the language
I'm just going to redefine it if the
leftist gets a redefine words if they
get to redefine racism uh redefine
Blackness and whiteness and all these
different things then screw it I'm going
to redefine it too and use it to my
advantage just like them
foreign
are you tired of using bulky old wallets
giving you a bulge where you don't want
it to be my old wallet was massive so it
brought all the ladies to the yard which
was a huge distraction and got in the
way of my esteemed work on trigonometry
reg wallets have an incredible solution
for you this is mine Sleek stylish and
with an industrial look to it can fit 12
cards with cash on the back using a clip
like this one or a strap we've got one
for the whole team I've got one Francis
has one even our producer Anthem has one
but he's from Liverpool so he flogged
his on the black market the great thing
about Ridge is that they give you a
lifetime guarantee which means if you
want you can have only one wallet for
the rest of your life Ridge are so
confident in the quality of their
product they will give you 45 days to
test drive their wallets that means you
can get the wallet use it and if you
don't like it you can return it within
45 days because Ridge is such great guys
they're going to give give you ten
percent off and free worldwide shipping
and returns to take advantage of this
incredible offer go to ridge.com forward
slash trigger that's ridge.com forward
slash trigger and use our special code
which is of course trigger
hello and welcome to trigonometry on
location whilst our brand new studio is
being built I'm Francis Foster I'm
Constantine kitchen and this is a show
for you if you want honest conversations
with Fascinating People our brilliant
guest today is a writer and the author
of black victim to Black Victor Adam
Coleman welcome to trigonometry thank
you for having me uh listen thank you
for having us uh in your Airbnb here in
London we were supposed to have you in
the studio but life got in the way but
we're really excited to have you on the
show uh tell everybody before we get
into it who are you how are you where
you are what has been the journey
through life that leads you to be
sitting here talking to us ah so many
Journeys um I would say that I I
generally say I'm a typical American I
was working a regular I.T job but kind
of got involved in the culture War just
watching you guys watching other
podcasts and just learning and there
became a moment where I felt like my
voice someone who actually sang things
that I wanted to be heard wasn't
actually saying it especially after the
death of George Floyd
The Narrative went from this was a
incident that is unfortunate and maybe
we need to look at police reform to The
Narrative of black men are constantly in
fear we're always in danger and that
racism is the number one issue affecting
us
and I thought that narrative was
insulting I thought that narrative was
incomplete and not true whatsoever uh
the number one issue facing black
Americans as a family we have a
dysfunctional family issue as far as
separation goes and I wanted the
opportunity to talk about it and write
about it but write about it in a way
that is
of substance you know there are people
who I generally agree with maybe even
conservatives who talk about family
values and the importance of fathers and
men but I always felt like it was
incomplete they said it like it was
something that people are just supposed
to know rather than explaining so people
fully understand the ramifications of
not having both parents within the home
so I wrote my book to actually tell my
personal story
and also examine and analyze a whole
bunch of different areas of what we
would consider Black Culture but I'm
very open about my childhood and how it
affected me and I think it sticks out
for people who read it because most of
the time people don't talk about this
thing they pretend that everything was
fine you know they made it through I'm
alive and everything is fine after that
but I wanted to paint a realistic
picture that my life was tumultuous
because my father wasn't there we were
homeless multiple times I remember a
woman who
came to my mother and said you can stay
with me
and my trailer I have one room and so
myself my mom and my sister stayed in
one room for at least a month or so
before my mom got back on her feet but I
remember bouncing in out of hotels
you know just to have some place to
sleep meanwhile going to school and my
mom's working
so you know having one income earner
within the home can put you in that risk
of
going in outside in and out of
homelessness and in fighting for
survival but I I just couldn't stand The
Narrative of single Parenthood as being
this uh wonderful achievement and no
matter what you do everything is fine
and we're incapable of saying that hey
maybe this isn't the best idea for your
children and we've put so much on female
empowerment that we ignore the kids
and one of the interesting things about
your story as well is you became a dad
at quite young age yourself and so here
you are 21 years old you haven't had a
dad or as you talk about even a male
role model your entire life and then
suddenly you're supposed to teach this
new creature
how to be a man right how do you do that
um well the first thing I told myself is
that I wasn't going to be my father
I remember specifically holding my son
thinking that uh so it's a pretty low
bar because my father wasn't there so
you just got to be there that's going to
be there that was that was basically the
starting point
um so you know I always just try to be
the father that I thought I wanted for
myself
um so I have a lot of communication with
my son uh you know I talk about spanking
um but from an aspect of why was I
spanking you know do I really need to
spank my son and he was pretty young
when I decided like I don't want to do
this anymore and I realized I was
repeating behavior that I had learned
from when I was a kid because my mom you
know she's managing this boy and all she
knows is physicality to keep him in line
when she didn't actually have to do that
and my son and I are very much similar
we're both sensitive we're we're both
we're both very I don't want to say like
intellectual but like introspective and
so you don't need to hit me you can
explain to me what I did wrong and I
won't do it again uh so basically since
I said I'm not going to spank him I just
stopped spanking him and he's 17 years
old now and we have a great relationship
because we talk and we communicate so
you know it's those different things
that I just tried to figure out what
works and what feels natural uh and much
of what I talk about is what feels
natural for men
what feels natural for me as a man and
once I started going towards what felt
natural everything kind of just fell
into place but as far as becoming a man
for myself I've said I've probably been
a man for about five years and I'm 38.
and it's because it's this long arduous
Journey because I'm starting from Ground
Zero as an adult and figuring out that
maybe I need to constantly improve
because I'm failing over and over and
over I'm failing in relationships with
women uh I feel like I'm not being a the
best father even though someone might
say you're doing a great job I don't
feel like I'm doing you know doing the
best job
um so it's just constantly re-examining
my life and wanting to constantly
improve uh to become the person I am
today
and what does it mean to Adam to be a
man
huh
um I would say confidence confidence is
number one
um a shirt being like a very sure of
yourself
um
protecting people especially people you
care about people you love protect your
children
um that's why I talk so much about the
need to you know fight against
mutilating children because our job as
men is to stick up for our kids and not
allow perverts to come in and and tell
you to you know chop up your kids
because they feel off you know we need
to protect our families we need to
protect our children in our society
but as far as being a man I mean those
are just a few yeah a few things that
are highly important and you we were
talking about single mothers and as a
teacher I saw the the effect that not
having a father in the home had on young
boys why is it do you think that we we
just keep perpetuating this myth
we're unwilling to criticize women
I mean I I think it's as simple as that
when you have one sex that is infallible
then like nothing ever changes you can
only have change when you can recognize
mistakes
but if they don't make mistakes we can't
change and everything that they do is
perfect so you know what it's weird
because I agree with you that yes in
there is a taboo about making criticisms
of female Behavior but I also think that
single Parenthood is quite often as it
was in your case well I look I don't
know maybe it wasn't but quite often the
fault of the man actually and it's the
man that wasn't there and demand that
now look you might say the woman you
know behaved in certain ways that made
sure he wasn't there or but but often it
isn't often it's just a man who can get
away with having kids with multiple
women so is it really a case of it's
like the women's fault that they're
single mothers or or is that was it
maybe that's not even what you were
saying so that's that's actually a great
point to bring up and I'll I'll use I
don't think I'm talking too much out of
turn but I'll use my mom as an example
uh not too long ago I asked my mom
did you ever want to get married she
said no I always wanted two kids
and so for me that tells me that she
wasn't marriage minded she just wanted
children and so I'm like some people
might say that's fine that's her
prerogative but is that the best
scenario to raise children in and we
know statistic after statistic that's
not the best way to raise children but
that is what she wanted and my father
was married just not to her my father
was always married and so she picked a
man who was unavailable to have two
children with and so you know this is
not to be harsh with my mother I love my
mother but the reality is that she
didn't make the best decision and my
father wasn't there because he was never
going to be there he was a married man
who had his own life and and I believe
he had children as well he was never
going to be involved in my life other
than paying child support through the
state so as much I hear what you're
saying and we're very quick to say
Debbie dads there's a lot of questions
to be had about women who specifically
do not want to get married and that's
becoming more and more prevalent they're
they're finding ways to freeze their
eggs they're finding ways to to find
some sort of way that they can have
children but they're not asking to have
families and that's different I agree
with you on that that's a very good
point yeah and
because we we don't talk about enough
the effect that not having a dad has on
kids so what do you think the effect is
of fatherlessness in homes oh man our
boundaries
you know
um there's the boundary aspect as far as
understanding
uh I'll use boys as an example since I
was a boy
um you know boys are
they're like high energy
they're like a high energy mass and you
need to teach them how to control their
energy otherwise they can hurt people
right there's a reason why Rough and
Tumble plays so important for boys
especially is because you teach them
boundaries when they go too far you also
teach them how to control their emotions
someone who's ready to assault you just
like that is someone who doesn't know
the boundaries who doesn't know how to
control their emotions and so that is
why you see Violent offenders typically
come from single-parent homes they
usually lack a male authority figure to
teach them how to control that energy
it's different for girls but for men we
are stronger we are deadlier I mean it's
it's the truth to say that we can
inflict pain much easier and we are
dangerous to uh to society if we're not
under control and the job of the father
is to control the energy of the boy
so for me you know thankfully I think
more genetically I'm just a calm
kid I was I was always a good calm kid
but the other side of that is be is that
I was very vulnerable and when I was
about five we moved out of Detroit where
I was born and we moved to suburbs and
we moved to actually four states uh
before I was 18. but I always asked what
if we stayed in Detroit
you know I know the state of Detroit uh
Public School System right and Detroit
hasn't changed much since the 80s when I
was born so what if I had stayed there
what would have my life been what would
I have been surrounded by uh would I
have been a statistic would I've been
dragged into these different things
because I know me and I was vulnerable
people could have led me into different
directions and I didn't have a male
authority figure to say you need to
leave these people alone
and some might say well your mother can
tell you that but it's different coming
from a man yeah yeah and when we talk
about in particular black boys and the
the vulnerability and also as well the
fact that they're more likely to be
murdered they're more likely to be
murdered by other black boys do you
attribute that to fatherlessness and a
lot of black boys growing up in a home
without a father
I I think gangs are a result of Lost
Boys
and then they grow up to become lost men
um gangs are some sort of group
association with male activity it's just
flawed male activity and I think one of
the things that a lot of people don't
understand is especially women don't
understand about men is that we're
Purpose Driven right if someone said
your job is to take this hammer and nail
things
you've given you've been given purpose
yeah it doesn't matter that it's a
simple activity you've been given
purpose and so now you feel useful in
society but what if no one gives you
purpose
right you're kind of empty and so you're
just searching for something that's why
gangs are attractive to lost kids who
were never given purpose never shown how
to excel in particular areas they feel
useless they say what's the point that's
why you see kids who just kind of act
out in class because they're like what's
the point of paying attention I have no
purpose in this particular environment I
might as well go out there and do
whatever so I think purpose is extremely
important for kids and I think if you're
talking about like gang violence in
particular that's that's one of those
areas that you see what happens when you
don't give young men purpose and do you
think the problem is as well with Role
Models they don't see you know they look
at the role models and who are the role
models that they're going to be aspiring
to it's somebody maybe in sports or
entertainment but the reality is very
few people make it in that Arena yeah
yeah absolutely and honestly for young
men Your Role Model should be your
father right it should be a healthy
Father Figure and that's what that's how
I see like everything through the prism
of family I see the very start from men
is your father it's supposed to be your
father and he's supposed to be who
you're mimicking and he's you're
supposed to reflect what he puts out
um and and become something productive
within the society but if that's not
there then like you said where do you
where do you get it from and a lot of
people get it from local uh if you're in
a negative area someone who's local to
you and whether it's negative or
positive you're just searching for some
sort of purpose something to mimic
um and if you see that something works
or appears to work then you're just
going to go in that direction but I
think
um as far as Role Models go it needs to
be fathers and I think we've we've honed
in too much on the role model aspect of
just saying any man will do right and
actually that's part of the problem with
a lot of women who do end up in single
parent situations they say well I need
to get a stepfather because any man will
do right and it's not the same and they
don't understand that on top of opening
up all different types of
vulnerabilities to kids
hey Constantine do you want better
mental health I'm from Russia we don't
have mental health so how do you deal
with mental health you drink Vodka then
go out and wrestle bear if you live you
feel better if you die you're not real
men what about the Bear's feelings it's
Russian Bear it has no feelings people
don't always realize that physical
symptoms like headaches teeth grinding
and even digestive issues can be
indicators of stress and let's not
forget about Doom scrolling not sleeping
enough sleeping too much under eating
and overeating sleeping too much under
eating this is Western disease therapy
has really helped me in my life to
concentrate and focus it's really
important to have someone impartial who
you can talk to about the tricky issues
that you're struggling to deal with
therapy has played a really important
role in helping me to deal with my ADHD
and become better in all areas of my
life why is he telling them how weak he
is drink Vodka feel better better help
is customized online therapy to offers
video phone and even live chat sessions
with your therapist so you don't have to
see anyone on camera if you don't want
to trigonometry funds get 10 off their
first month at betterhelp.com forward
slash trigger especially if they're not
real men that's b e t t e r h e l p.com
slash trigger
it's an interesting uh set of
interesting points that you make I think
as a new father myself it's one of the
things that I've I'm thinking about all
the time is like oh wow like someone
looking to me now I've got to be you
were talking about this earlier you've
got to be the best version of you
because you are now a role model to
other people so you've got to get your
own emotions under control you've got to
you know you've got to be conscious
about how you are in the world right
um but moving on slightly on to the sort
of broader political stuff that you
touched on earlier we interviewed a
woman called Mary ebastad a while ago
who wrote a book called Primal screams
how the sexual Revolution created
identity politics and her Central
argument is essentially this that if you
have generation upon generation of
children growing up and uh broken homes
essentially you know if you use that
term of course they're looking for some
kind of group to belong to of course
they want to go oh I'm black they're for
other black people you know all of that
do you do you see that as as a
contributing factor to this identity
politics stuff that we now see in
society yeah I you know I noticed that
the people who um
for example I I notice not sorry I
noticed people who grew up in two parent
homes happy two parent homes and how
they're not so much in love with you
know the pigmentation of their skin
right they're they're in love with being
uh whether they're a Christian being a
mother a father they have so many other
things identity wise that are more
important than the color of their skin
and I see the opposite I see people who
grow up in dysfunction who are looking
for some sort of group Association group
identity
um I I even went through a phase of that
where I'm I'm searching for who am I you
know and I got into a little bit of the
I would identify as like a Neo Marxist
kind of stuff listen to those speakers
um who are you listening to uh like for
example like Tim Wise for example and I
was like oh these guys kind of
interesting
um I don't know him what's his message
oh you know white supremacy
I mean yeah and he he actually happens
to be white but him among other a lot of
them do yeah yeah that's true
um but you know just listen to other
speakers and and stuff like that
um I remember hearing the the new age
term for racism power post privilege
right right you know and I remember
hearing all these different things
and then I started believing it a little
bit and then I looked around me I was
like but that doesn't match my reality
and that's why I kind of moved away from
it wait how did Adam sorry I know I
can't control but I'm just really
curious about this part of it
how does someone who is listening to
these kind of narratives
look around and see that it's not what
did you see that wasn't congruent with
that world view well if I'm perfectly
blunt my son is mixed my son's half
white
um I've been a relationship with women
who are white my wife currently is black
you know I've grown up in neighborhoods
where I'm the minority I've grown up in
neighborhoods where I'm I've mixed other
kids so my reality has been like people
are people
and so this idea that there's like this
Legacy of white people who are just
passing on generation and generation to
hate black people I'm not seeing it to
the level that these people are talking
about
um and I think one of the things that I
didn't like is that they're preaching
animosity
like they want me to feel resentful of
not of this person's issue but of their
grandparents and that theoretically
their grandparents because maybe it
wasn't their grandparents for all I know
their their grandparents were in Italy
and now I'm supposed to hate you because
of someone from you know it to me it
just didn't make any sense to live my
life in such a resentful angry kind of
way
and I and I'm troubled by people who are
preaching that they're preaching
um don't forgive right don't forgive
these people who had absolutely nothing
to do with what you're doing
um who are laying all types of excuses
for someone's personal failures
um it reminds me of a conversation I had
with um a family member of mine
who you know he doesn't preach this per
se but he would consider himself
pro-black and I said you know all right
fine
but let's just say this does it help you
to have multiple baby mamas
right if you think the white man is
oppressing you how does it help you to
have two baby mamas and three kids
does it at all right how does it help
you to have a separation of family
it doesn't you have one income earner in
the house how does that help you when
you could have two right if uh white
people are setting up a system where
we're going to make less why do you have
less people in the household who can
make less
you know so I'm just being very logical
about the situation of the world around
me even if you want to be pro-black and
believe in all this stuff let's go back
to family build up the family and and
you'll change all different types of
outcomes I think that's a great message
so talking about thinking logically and
not thinking logically summer of 2020
you brought up George Floyd yeah this
terrible thing happens and it was a
terrible thing that happened and the
world goes absolutely apeshit
what was your you said you had some
thoughts about that that weren't being
reflected what was your take on that
my my take on it was well for me I'm one
of those people who likes to sit back
and watch the reaction of people so not
even
it wasn't necessarily George Floyd but
it was the reaction to George Floyd that
I was reacting to and it was like
watching people let's say they were
black that people that I knew who had
happy successful lives all of a sudden
became victims
and they and it was like they were
talking about a world that they were not
living in whatsoever and and I'm just
like how did we get to this point in
just a matter of days where everybody it
to me it felt like a panic attack it
felt like America was having a panic
attack
um and they were as someone who suffered
from panic attacks it just looking like
a rational view of the world and and I'm
like but look around you everything is
actually fine like this is unfortunate
but this black person has nothing to do
with you
right and so look at your world
Let them fight that fight with George
Floyd but your world is not George
Foley's world and and I want people to
realize that but it just felt like the
media was all in on uh using basically
black plight as some motivating factor
that you must go out into the streets
and apparently it's okay to burn things
down it's mostly peaceful anyways so I
just had a problem with
and I'm going to use the group identity
uh them labeling black men as being in
constant fear
um and actually it reminded me of an
article I wrote for the New York Post
talking about actually Jonathan Capehart
who wrote this op-ed after
um Buffalo's mass shooting which they
said you know there's white supremacists
who targeted a black neighborhood and
shot the people
and that's highly unfortunate but he
made this
um this vision of black people are
constantly in fear and and he's hinting
at leaving the country himself this
millionaire who lives in DC he's not
leaving the country right but at the end
he He makes himself the hero and says
I'm not leaving I'm going to stay here
right and and I thought to myself white
supremacy is the constant uh picturing
of black people as being fearful scared
incapable and the only way they can
succeed is by the uh by white people's
good grace or the government coming in
and doing something for them to me
that's white supremacy and that's what I
was watching I'm watching watching white
supremacy happening in front of me of
them saying look at these poor black
people we need to do something for them
you have white intellectuals who you
know the robin D'Angelos and and all
these different people who are coming
out and say look at the black play we
have to do something for these people
right and I'm saying we can do for
ourselves
like and and just because I am black
doesn't mean I I share the same
experience as this other person just
like you're a white and you don't share
the same experience as every other white
person like to me it just removed our
individuality and we just became this
Collective that was just weak and feeble
and everybody must do for us and
everybody must say our narrative and
speak for us and then what made it worse
is that we have the black bourgeoisie
that goes out there and repeats these
narratives because they get social
benefits from them they get the
affirmative action out of this narrative
right because they always benefit from
it they get to go to the Ivy League
schools and have their kids go to the
Ivy League schools because they fit that
quota right it doesn't benefit any other
black person just like it doesn't
benefit any other black person when a
black head coach gets hired and they
become a millionaire all of a sudden how
does that benefit me but I'm supposed to
clap and cheer of you know the
benevolence of the NFL for hiring
another black person so there's there's
a class element to it as well that I I
constantly bring up but that story with
Jonathan Capehart pissed me off so much
that I wanted to say that he's the black
face of white supremacy not Larry Elder
right and if we're going to have
blackfees the white supremacy then this
is the guy who's doing it and he's one
of many who who does it Adam doesn't it
worry you that we just Bandy the term
white supremacy about just willy-nilly
and you think this is actually something
very very serious there are white
supremacists they're white supremacists
here there's white supremacists in
America and all we do when we use this
term over and over again is we just
devalue it yeah and I think I think we
should devalue it because it it's not
that much of value anyways if if I label
someone as a white supremacist then what
then what you know they they did it to
themselves they cried wolf too many
times so I'm I'm one of those people who
actually doesn't want to fight the
language I'm going to use the language
I'm just going to redefine it if the
leftist gets a redefine words if they
get to redefine racism uh redefine
Blackness and whiteness and all these
different things then screw it I'm going
to redefine it too and use it to my
advantage just like them
uh because I think
we shouldn't fight language as hard as
we're trying to because it makes it seem
like we're hiding something right I'm
not a white supremacist you know like it
was like oh white supremacist would say
that
and so we we should actually
use the words to our advantage because
you can right and that's the magic of
the English language how do you how to
use the words to your advantage I use it
to my advantage by redefining them just
like how they use it to their eventually
redefine it the reason they're able to
get away with racist narratives is
because they redefine what racism is and
so it's our job now to redefine the
redefinition of racism back to its
appropriate point it's our turn to use
their their lingo and use it against
them to prove our Point as to what we're
actually trying to say so give me an
example well the white supremacy aspect
right to me I I'm not going to fight
white supremacy I'm not going to fight
the usage of the wording we use it too
much I'm going to leave it in the
Lexicon and redefine it
because now then they're on the back
foot of saying well you know we'll just
use another word you know it's like all
right fine Bring up another word and
I'll fight it if you try to redefine it
so I want us to battle the definitions
of words and and keep redefining it
every time they redefine it we do it
again uh rather than trying to say this
word shouldn't be used as much because
it minimize no it's already here people
use these words I remember years ago no
one ever said white supremacy
now they do so we can't get people to
not say it anymore the only thing we can
do is redefine it to its appropriate
usage
do you not think as well that it's very
dangerous when they use these words
because like I said there are genuine
white supremacists and they'll just say
Well everybody's a white supremacist now
therefore what does that mean so they
can kind of hide under the cover of this
word being misused or misappropriated
well
here's the thing I think we genuinely
have white supremacists but we don't
Define it the way that it should be
defined I think the majority of social
progressives are white supremacists so
that's why I actually think we should
keep the word in the Lexicon because
these people are you know a lot of them
are the black the black Elite who came
for them they're the white elite who are
socially Progressive who are in all of
our institutions they're part of
government they're part of the media
they have influence in our society
they're in Hollywood they're actually
white supremacists in my eyes
hold on white supremacy in its actual
definition is the belief that the white
people are genetically inherently
Superior to everybody else and should
have power in society because of that so
how are social progressives white
supremacist under that definition well
I would say the white supremacists by
action right so if you say
um the only way that Adam can succeed is
if I do something for him that pleases
you above me correct it makes you
stronger than me because I can't do for
myself and that is the environment that
we currently live in as far as in the
media and as far as how even the
government operates now there's poor
black people they need our help right no
I totally get it and I think one of the
things you talk about uh in uh black
victim to Black Victor is the idea of
having a victim requires a savior
absolutely and so this ideology is
particularly appealing to certain people
who want to be victims and want
government help or other people to look
after them or whatever but even more so
is really appealing to people who want
to help the poor downtrodden black and
brown people exactly uh that is that's
actually going to be the topic of my
next book is the savior ISM Xavier
here's an aspect of it
that is something that is motivating a
lot of our society regardless of race
people who want to save the world people
who want to save the unfortunate
transgender people who are being
maligned everybody just feels like they
must do to save other people but it
they're given the illusion that it's
they're only doing it to help other
people but they're doing it for
themselves right no one's asking them to
do it they're taking it upon themselves
they're forcing other people to to
become activists and take these
initiatives they're they're doing it to
promote themselves it's not a selfless
act it's very selfish of them to do so
and it's very
um narcissistic I think that's the best
way of kind of putting it it's very
narcissistic Vision that I must do for
other people because they can't do for
themselves and they'll use every every
angle every statistic every possibility
to make sure that people understand that
I must do these things for society
because I must save Society but don't
you think as well Adam
or kind of basic explanation to it which
is it's much easier to save someone else
or than to actually deal with your own
problems you know because dealing with
your own problems let's be fair it's
[ __ ] hard yeah whereas going and you
know fighting for the world or whatever
else you know you don't have to deal
with the fact that maybe you're not good
at X Y and Z right and and even fighting
for the world is an empty gesture like
who is actually fighting for what is you
holding a picket sign actually changing
much of anything I mean it's very low
bar activity to change something who
knows is sitting in the middle of the
road actually going to stop climate
change in your Fusion but you just feel
like you must do something right and it
puts you at at the center Focus but it's
even more damning when they put
themselves to the center Focus uh
and it hurts other people in the process
right they're willing to do it despite
it hurting other people they're willing
to do it despite how it makes other
people look uh how it inconveniences you
from going to work they don't care they
want to sit in the road because me
saving Society is more important than
you going to to your job and to support
your family
um so it's it's a much more
I would say malevolent kind of activity
that people don't really recognize or at
least they haven't been able to Define
it the way I'm trying to Define it but I
think it's much so saviorism that is
just plaguing at least America and
probably here it's plaguing our society
and the most powerful people have it the
worst yeah yeah well we import all your
craps so no doubt whichever way America
goes we'll get it but it sounds to me
like in some ways what I'm hearing out
of our conversation is actually the
answer to this savior is
activism isn't counteractivism actually
it's perhaps promoting some very
old-fashioned things like the ones we've
been talking about from the beginning
which is family uh you know uh agency
the idea that your job is to better your
own life and to improve yourself as
opposed to looking out into the world
and God this is what needs to change and
these people need my help with this
actually look inside you know are you a
parent are you a good one I what are you
doing with your life are you trying to
get better Etc is that how you feel this
needs to change or do you think that
there's more structural stuff that needs
have to happen as well I think uh if
you're going to change anything in
society you have to start within your
own home
um that's why I always go back to family
if family disappears and and the vision
of family disappears then our society
disappears I think that is the number
one thing that we need to focus on and I
think it means something when we're
watching things that look incredibly
different than when our grandparents
live through
um and then we're looking at aspects of
society was like this is terrible like
it just doesn't work it doesn't
functionally work and when I tell people
that the United States is number one in
single Parenthood
and I look at all these different areas
and I know that what happens
behaviorally for kids who grow up in
single-parent homes what they're more
likely to do uh you know people like to
say United States incarcerates the most
people well guess where these people
come from are you think they're just
happy one day and woke up and just
started breaking the law started hurting
people just cause like no a lot of times
it is a cycle that leads down to this
point where they get caught up into
something they feel like they have no
other choice or they have no control of
their impulses because no one taught
them how to control their impulses you
know you have all these different things
these different areas that come down to
what happens at the family affects the
rest of society and then for the people
who fail to properly raise their
children to manage their family the rest
of us pay for it right you now have to
pay more security for your home because
of a degenerate who grew up in a
dysfunctional home now wants to take
your stuff right you now have to be
worried about your safety as you're
walking down the street at night because
someone who's coming from a messed up
home who's now addicted to to cover for
that pain is now trying to take
something from you or willing to harm
you to to get what they want right the
rest of society pays for the failures of
families and I don't think people fully
understand that
hey Francis if you were a member of the
public would you like the opportunity to
ask incredible guests like Bill Burr
Jordan Peterson Sam Harris Adam Carolla
Brett Weinstein John Barnes Douglas
Murray Nigel farage and Lionel Shriver
your own questions you bet I would and
what do you think the best way to do
that would be uh probably stalking mate
you'd have to Corner them in the
supermarket probably around near like
the sort of frozen food of and then just
bought questions at them before they can
escape not the American ones as they
have guns and you'd have to be extra
careful with the females as that's how I
got in trouble last time do you really
imagine you're gonna get Douglas Murray
near the frozen food aisle if you want
to ask our incredible guest questions
and have access to phenomenal behind the
scenes content then you have to be on
our locals that's right for only seven
dollars a month you get incredible extra
content behind the scenes footage
giveaways and also the chance to be part
of an incredible Community where you can
meet and hang out with like-minded
people you get access to our American
Vlogs as we travel across the country
interviewing Our Heroes an extra 20
minutes of our viral Sam Harris episode
as he discusses his approach to covert
we're also going to start doing
giveaways of exclusive trigonometry
merchandise like this a poster from our
Edinburgh show signed by both of us and
also a House of Lords Teddy which you
can only get in the House of Lords
signed by the one and only baroness Fox
locals also gives you access to an
incredible online community you can
share memes talk about the latest
episode or even make a new friend or
just one exactly more than both of us
have really people are now doing meetups
in their City because they love locals
in fact some people enjoy it so much
they prefer it over the show they prefer
locals to trigonometry
if I have to get them executed I'm the
one that goes to jail right go to
trigonometry.locals.com only seven
dollars a month for all that incredible
content
trigonometry.locals.com See you there
guys
it's it's a tough message to hear but it
but it's a necessary one do you think
we're ever going to have this
conversation in the mainstream in an
open and honest fashion or do you think
we're always going to just try and brush
it under the carpet simply because it's
so difficult to hear I think there's
always a boiling point
um I think the fact that I'm sitting
here talking to you about this is a good
sign
um and I I see other people who are
starting to talk about the importance of
men importance of fathers how it's
affecting them how it's affecting their
kids
um I think feminism has brought a raw
deal to families and especially to women
I think feminism hates women to be
honest with you
um but I I think that aspect of just
going full force into feminism and to
say women are you know infallible and
and just not caring about how it this
Viewpoint affects children how it
affects the fathers how it affects
anything else between this this um bond
between the mother and the father and
children
um and just going towards High
individualism High you know
self-preservation like no sacrifice you
know it's that kind of it's kind of a
sick world that we're we're promoting
that we're saying this is perfectly fine
because this is what this person wants
and everything is fine because of it
it's like no we had rules for a reason
we had boundaries for a reason we had
standards for a reason I remember uh
years ago when I was a kid someone who
would have a child out of wedlock was
sometimes looked sideways now it's like
no one cares and and that is part of the
problem and and
we're not willing to criticize people
who are involved in those particular
situations I actually agree with almost
everything he said but I'm just I want
to uh ask you what you mean when you say
feminism hates women
feminism hates women because we we have
feminists who watch our show yeah uh and
I think the difficulty with a statement
like that for me is there's about 73
different ways of being feminist yeah
and if the basic core of it you're
talking about men and women should be
treated fairly and equally yeah I've got
no issue with that I don't think you
have any issue with that either so you
what kind of feminism are you talking
about and what do you mean exactly I
would say because everybody has like the
different ways I would say modern
feminism so modern feminism hates women
because it tells them to be everything
that isn't natural to being a woman
right it says in order for you to
succeed in the world you must be like
men right so you must be aggressive like
men but they always come out to be too
aggressive because men are usually
successful men are men measured in their
aggressiveness it tells them to get rid
of marriage right it's all about your
career well actually men have careers in
marriage right so it sends them all
these mixed messages and I think a lot
of women end up hurt because of it and
they're unhappy because of it
um you know I I consume all different
types of content and I sometimes watch
content where women are in their mids to
late 30s and 40s who are regretful
because they did want children but they
were told not to have children or they
did want to get married but they were
telling they were told that marriage is
old-fashioned and you don't need to get
married you know they're being told to
do things that isn't natural to them and
they're now regretful when you know they
start to leave that bubble of feminism
um and it and it actually feminism
really promotes things that benefit men
especially very successful men or men
who are able to
it's Wonder Woman so to speak or who are
very attracted to women they get sex
from it you know
we're no longer allowed to criticize
female sexuality whatsoever
um and if you want to have sex have sex
but now it's like it doesn't even matter
if it's Reckless sex it doesn't even
matter if it's sex work it doesn't none
of it matters anymore and so who
benefits from it the most men men who
can get a lot of sex they benefit from
it so I'm asking myself like how is
feminism actually helping women today
it's not really they're unhappier
they're taking more pharmaceutical drugs
at least in the United States they're
taking a lot of pharmaceutical drugs to
suppress this uneasiness I don't see how
it benefits women whatsoever it's an
interesting point that you make because
one of our best recent interviews with
is with a woman called Louise Perry
who's written a book called the case
against the sexual Revolution and I
think she's going to be over time
develop into almost like a petersonian
type figure because in the same way that
Jordan Peterson had a message for men
that they have not heard but really
needed to hear which is the your job as
a man and is to get better and improve
your life stop whining get on with it
the only way you're going to get
anything is by being different is by
being better is by working harder is by
being true to who you are Etc and that's
why I think Jordan Peterson became such
a huge figure because he came in at the
right moment with the right message and
I think Louise who is talking about
actually just she puts up in a more
delicate way than you do but but her
message is similar which is we've been
sold a lie yeah uh women and I I totally
agree and when I I you know as a new
father I see the transformation of my
wife becoming a mum and how fulfilled
she is doing that
um I think a lot of women haven't been
reminded at least that that option is
still there you could be a mum first and
do other things second and quite often
that will be the most fulfilling thing
that you do do and that's okay and
Society hasn't been good at
communicating that to women I think so I
think you're right and I think you're
going to start to see that change as you
say as the generation Our Generation of
women who are getting to the point where
they're not quite child-bearing age
anymore right disappointed in some of
the choices they've made that is going
to feed doubt into the culture and I I'm
I wouldn't be surprised if like people
who are in their 20s now
start having kids younger actually
despite all the difficulties the housing
crisis and all of that but speaking of
the of the younger generation uh I
wanted to ask you if if you think this
will naturally turn uh or do you think
uh you know it's not going to be a kind
of Action Reaction type of situation I'm
I'm optimistic
um but I don't think the change is going
to necessarily happen with within this
generation I think it's going to be the
next Generation
Um
I think sometimes what happens is you
have to see the mistakes of the previous
generation
to realize like maybe we shouldn't do
that you know progress is good when it's
good progress
um
yeah
to progress just for progressives sake
like it doesn't make any sense if it's
works if it works then let it work
um and I think
uh the nuclear family works
but we're being told that it doesn't and
we have to ask the question why are we
being told this and who is perpetuating
this message and why are we even
listening to these people uh who
controls this narrative and so that's
why I think it's important that we
disconnect right we disconnect from
social media every so often we
disconnect from the television movies
because they are putting out certain
messages they are showing that men are
weak right and and women are just super
strong and they have no they have no
story arc as a superhero you know
they're showing these particular
messages but when you disconnect from it
and then you go and look and just ask
yourself like who's happy
like who is genuinely happy right and I
look at people who are in long-term
relationships they look happy
right there's just no some of them yeah
that is true yeah I'm just joking and I
know exactly the point yeah yeah I would
say the happiest people are the people
that I've seen who are in long-term
success relationships the most uh
depressed
the most depressed the the unhappiest
tend to be people who struggle with
relationships
um and they they struggle sometimes
because of their own doing a lot of
times because of their own doing
um and and they're moving away from
things because they feel that it is
beneath them
um like for example it's perfectly fine
to cook for your man like that doesn't
make you beneath him that's actually
something that is if we give and it's
also fine that if he protects you like
that's not beneath him that is something
that he's doing for you as well like we
have exchanges within relationships
gives and takes sacrifices you know
these are naughty words these days but I
think it's important that we sacrifice
for each other that's how you have a
success for family and how are you going
to be a selfish parent right how does
that work you have to sacrifice for your
children you have to be willing to say
you know what I'm not going to do this
because they're more important and I
think that is the magic of becoming a
parent that's what made me a better man
growing up was saying like I got to stop
messing around and I gotta take maybe
some risks I gotta do whatever I have to
do to make sure that my son is good and
so you ask before like growing up
becoming a man a lot of it had to do
with my son and having him early forced
me to say this is bigger than me and now
today now that he's 17
for me speaking up and saying something
is the most important thing for me to do
because I don't want him to say how come
my dad didn't say something how come my
dad was sitting back and acting like a
coward meanwhile he's telling me these
things oh this is crazy and I didn't do
anything about it and and
it doesn't seem like it it takes a lot
of effort to really just like say
something you know for me to sit down
and write a book and I had never written
anything before
and and to go into it and express myself
and put it out there part of the reason
I wrote that book is because of my son
I wanted to write a book years prior but
I didn't know what to write about but
the reason I wanted to write a book is
because I was thinking about my legacy
and what I wanted to leave for my son so
my son is my legacy but I wanted to
leave something that he can always
remember and be proud of his father
about so that is part of the reason why
I wrote my book and he read it and he
understands his father much more after
reading this book and I I'm just trying
to show people like do something
you know I'm I'm an I.T guy by trade and
if I can get up one day and just sit
down and write and express myself and
put myself out there for criticism and
be critical of the world around me and
and have some success because of it
like why can't other people do it but
you know you have to become an example
for your kids if you sit back and you
cower and you cry and complain and you
do nothing about it you're teaching that
to your kids as well so I tell my son to
question everything including me and do
something about it if you don't like how
something is go and do something about
it but don't don't sit there and
complain right and and if I'm going to
tell him that I have to do it as well
right yeah right it's interesting uh
that you mentioned that because uh
having my son had the exact same effect
on me like right away because I went
okay look I oppose identity politics
because I just think it's racist right
right
and I've always done it and I've always
said it and I've taken the risks and
we've done the show together talking
about it whatever but the moment he was
born I was like wait there are idiots
out there who are going to judge him
this this pure thing that is just pure
potentiality he he hasn't said a word he
hasn't moved he hasn't done anything all
all he does is eat and poo right but
they they've already judged him right
that's wrong right I'm not prepared to
live in a world in which that's
happening and I haven't said anything
right and and same actually same thing
for for me my son is mixed race and you
know I remember years ago I asked some
like do you see yourself as black or
white and he says I just see myself as
Daniel right and I'm like that's a fair
answer and it's unfair to put kids who
are in mixed race situations to pick one
side and and you know
I think I think it's just an unfair
world like you said the identity
politics creates
um rather than seeing us as humans with
superficial differences because that's
all it really is my son looks like me
but just a little bit lighter skin but
he is a good person he is a good kid and
he's going to grow up to be someone who
is beneficial for society and that's all
that really matters yeah um you know
group identity
you know humans are group related you
can't defeat that right and sometimes
it's good nationalism sometimes is good
you know we're always going to find some
sort of group orientation that's how we
survive but it's when it runs amok it's
when it becomes the only thing that we
care about and the only thing that we
focus on
um and saying that we are we're
completely different because you have
more pigmentation or less pigmentation
that's when we start going down a realm
that feels dirty in my opinion it
doesn't even matter who the perpetrators
are it doesn't matter if they're black
or white hispanic it doesn't matter what
they are there is something wrong about
holy prejudging People based off of
characteristics and I think we've seen
what happened in human history when we
went down that path wholeheartedly and
also as well the thing to bear in mind
Adam is in a few years this is not going
to matter because we're all going to be
transracial anyway we're going to be
able to identify as whatever we want yes
I mean following in the footsteps of the
great man Justin Trudeau
oh yes the great Justin Trudeau
um
yeah I think
I would say this
um
the reason I part of the reason I'm
speaking out is because I feel like the
average American doesn't have a voice
and I feel like I am much of the average
American
um I'm much of the average American
economically life experience and you
know obviously I went through some
things that maybe other people didn't go
through but I always felt like the
average person
and when I talk to other people they're
average people too and we have like all
these narratives of being created by a
certain group of people about us but I'm
like none of these people are like this
like I've been like I said I've lived in
four states before I was 18 and I lived
in Tennessee as an adult
um but I've seen all different types of
errors in different people people are
people you know this idea that people
are just waking up waiting to hate
somebody
oh you know overall that that's our
mainstream Viewpoint As Americans that's
not the America that I live in and we're
painting this picture and and the
American people don't have a voice
uh within the media
um within society that is being
projected like Hey we're fine we're good
like I really don't care that Adam is
black like he's black that's fine but I
care that he's a good person and all
these different things you know we were
talking about Tennessee one of my
favorite things about living in
Tennessee was that people just come up
and talk to you
you know and being from New Jersey I'm
not used to that
but I would be standing in line and some
lady she was an older white lady she'd
just come and talk to me and start
telling me about her family she didn't
care that I was black she just she saw
me as a person there and she was just
communicating with me like and that's
been my experience for a lot of
different places that I've lived at
obviously I've had
um some racial incidences but I could
count them on one hand thankfully
maybe some people have a little bit more
or maybe some people misinterpret things
but overall Americans are generally good
people who just want to go to work take
care of the kids and and have enough
economics to to do some extra things but
this idea that you know we're these
highly sinful people who are just
waiting to do things and have these
malevolent thoughts and and you know I
think that a lot of it is actually
projection by the people who are
delivering the message and one thing
that I want to touch on which your son
would be able to speak about is the
mixed rice experience because if we
start looking at everything through a
racial lens then we'll go oh this person
is you know uh darker skinned
African-American therefore they have
this experience therefore you are more
privileged because you were lighter
because and it's just never ending isn't
it it just never ends it never ends and
then
I don't know if you guys have heard of
like the one drop rule yeah yeah okay we
actually kind of have that still so so
just explain to people who haven't heard
of it what the one drop rule is please
Adam so the one drop rule is like it's
basically I'm probably gonna butcher it
a little bit but it's basically like if
you have one drop of black blood then
you're black so it doesn't matter
anything else it doesn't matter if half
you know a quarter is this a quarter is
that quarter is that well a good example
is Barack Obama half white the first
black president yeah no one called him
mixed race until after 10 years could
have gone by yeah exactly and if someone
meets my son and he's he's pretty
light-skinned but if they meet him and
they find out that I'm black then they
would say well they he's black right
right uh or you know there's you're a
quarter black you know it's just like
everything is about the one drop rule
and and it's a it's a weird dynamic to
constantly see and I almost feel like it
it um it erases people like it raises
people in the people's individualism
um to kind of see things through the
prism of how much blood do you have or
what blood do you have even more so
um but that's it's a natural
consequences uh natural consequence of
tribal group identity because if some
groups are better than others or some
groups are worse than others then
naturally people will want to be in a
particular group or will be forced to be
in that group as opposed to just going
I'm Daniel well it's an interesting
point you talk about you know people are
people uh when we interviewed Bill Burr
when we we went to America this is the
point that he made which is like he
started playing all these black clubs
and initially as a white guy who maybe
hasn't been in that environment you've
got all these black people blah blah
blah and then once you're used to it you
start to see oh that's my that that guy
just like my friend Steve who's an
[ __ ] you know what I mean and that
that's really the simple messages people
are people and look I've I think we've
all really enjoyed this conversation I
think the conversation about family and
parenting and masculinity and all of of
that is going to be a big part of not
only the conversation going forward I
actually think it's a big part of the
solution too I think if
if we can do what you're talking about
which is focus on encouraging people not
going back to the 1950s but actually
going forward what is the constructive
view of the future well it's got to be
you know I I becoming a new parent has
opened my eyes to how anti-natal our
society is it's incredible I remember I
remember reading your book going oh it
became a dad of 21. wow
what what what's so weird about becoming
a dad at 21. this isn't it's what human
beings have done for Millennia right
it's completely normal yet in our
society we think of that as some kind of
crazy thing right you know
um so anyway I just I'm really glad we
had this conversation I think what
you're talking about is going to be a
big part of the way this issue gets
talked about but also whether some of
these things get resolved going forward
so I really appreciate you coming on the
show thank you um and uh as always we've
got one more question for you which is
what is the one thing we're not talking
about but we really should be
um the vulnerability of children in
single parent homes to sexual
molestation
um I I I'll go back to I tried to end on
a positive
Jesus Christ you don't know maybe
there's a great joke at the end of it
let's do it
I gave him all this uplifting stuff
about he's doing the right things
yeah
all right but we joke you make a very
good point and uh my friend uh Holly who
used to work with Brett and Heather
Brett Weinstein and Heather hiing uh she
always talks about this as well so go
for it yeah
um basically I don't think people
understand the safety aspect when it
comes to having someone who who is an
adult especially a male brought into the
home of a child that is not theirs
um and how much vulnerability that
leaves because Predators look for
vulnerabilities and men who are looking
for child or children to you know
basically pray off of
they're going to look for single mothers
that is a reality and I remember having
this conversation on a podcast and there
were three guys there and I was
explaining how this would all work and
and and how this is a major
vulnerability and when I finished
speaking one of the guys said you
basically explained my childhood to a t
everything that I explained as to what
happens to these kids and how vulnerable
they become
he basically went through and his story
is the silent story that people don't
feel comfortable talking about so for me
it's
there's the childhood behavioral aspect
but safety right children are safer with
both of their natural parents within the
home obviously there are good step
parents they exist right but I cannot
deny the statistics that exist when it
it's not even close how much danger
children are in uh when they're along
with a parent who is not their
biological parent uh whether it be
physical abuse or sexual abuse yeah and
a lot of times as well this is a really
tragic thing and I saw it as a teacher
just kids and when they hit 16 step dad
doesn't want them around out they go
onto the streets yeah and then they
become part of the homelessness problem
right and a lot of the times those kids
are super vulnerable and they fall
through the cracks in the system and
it's heartbreaking because they haven't
even started yet and they're already
about minus 500 whatever it is it's
heartbreaking yeah nice uplifting yeah
everybody no I I joke because just to
use the tension but actually I think you
both make a really important point I'm
so glad you brought this up it really
needs to be talked about Adam uh black
victim to Black Victor is the book uh so
so great to have you on the show really
appreciate it we're going to ask you a
couple of questions that our local
supporters have submitted that only they
will get to see the answer to but for
the moment thank you so much for coming
on the show my pleasure uh and thank you
guys for watching and listening we will
see you with another brilliant episode
like this one or raw show all of them go
out 7pm UK time and for those of you who
like your trigonometry on the go it's
also available as a podcast take care
and see you soon guys
how do you start a friendly conversation
to change someone's self-perceived
victimhood